there's no cord on USB there is I mean
you could do a USB drive which doesn't
have a cord or you could do USB actual
good
pretty little pieces we don't know [__]
about us B what is
it for uh Universal Service Bureau
[Music]
welcome to a very special episode of the
careful boys
um we have a new face here oh
[Applause]
here we go yeah what's your last name
Cummings David Cummings and uh we're not
even gonna talk about you right now
because unfortunately our friend
got a carjacked today so it's kind of
the most interesting thing in my room
but we'll be we'll be back with you
listen I did that because I knew you
were coming and we really didn't want to
focus on you no I I knew that
yeah we're all in on it should have
steal the show again I didn't want to
shake your hand when you clean so I said
I know you already
loading because you know we're talking
about some insurance fraud here too oh
what potentially potentially what do you
mean she hasn't decided if she wants to
commit it or not oh got it okay
yeah it's probably gonna be uploaded in
a couple of months months yeah or next
month I just mean a Hot Topic if you
want
what's the deal dude what happened so
what happened to your car all right so
I go to my garage
at 8 20 in the morning to come drive
here wow yeah pretty early it is it is
three in the afternoon right now that
always shows up first well I'm also kind
of further than most but
um so I go to my spot and my car's not
there
and so I'm clicking like my car alarm
button thinking that it would just
appear or maybe I parked in the wrong
spot which
I never do that
um
and so I'm like cool well there's two
options either
somebody towed my car
and it's a mistake the wrong Philly toe
wrongfully toad or
my car got stolen oh you can't be that
yeah no [__] way [__] way not me
what's up there not not me is your area
secure with Gates so it it is gated
um and it's also on the lower level
garage and is there security there is
one security person oh they were
sleeping on a job
I stole your car dude their security
cameras at you know in 2023 now aren't
in 4k so this is so so lovely
um should have got a Google oh my God
not good enough what kind of car it was
good for sports oh we're gonna get there
geez and you could give us the footage
so we could show them this is the song
It's a Bugatti it's it's not it's a Kia
guys it's a Kia it's a good dance you
know what though that's been a thing you
know the Keo boys yeah yep yep they say
all you need is a thumb drive it's a USB
USB that's what I mean wait for real yep
yeah just steal it the whole car but is
a great company thanks to social media
and Tick Tock everybody knows this now
as of three months ago
um cord yeah like the actual USB
got you yeah there's no cord on USB
there is I mean you could do a USB drive
which doesn't have a corridor you could
do USB actual you get a [__] moded
little piece of [__] we don't know [__]
about usb
what does USB stand for uh Universal
Service Bureau
Dunked On Me
you [__] idiot
so I go to my uh my manager she's in her
office and um
I tell her hey my car is missing pretty
sure it got stolen and she was like why
no way
it never happens here yeah apparently it
does happen here yeah
um
so we go to the security cameras and
we're just scrubbing through from 2PM
yesterday to 8 30 in the morning today
we find at 2 30 a.m
um
two guys I believe it's two guys in a
silver or gray Toyota Camry so this is a
4k camera uh this is a like 320p camera
security camera well you can still
enhance it
what time was that so they they came in
at 2 30 in the morning witching hour
yeah nothing good happens
you should be asleep that's what my
grandmother said yeah you should be
asleep or committing sins so they get
into the the P1 garage uh with their car
and they searched the P1 garage for
various things they go down and then
they come right back up with my car in
first place there's in second
and they just Escape right out so
between 2 30 to 2 37 in the morning
um damn man that sucks dude I'm sorry I
wonder how they knew like your car or
did they just decide to go in this thing
that says key on it probably maybe that
yeah but they'd have to go in there to
know that there's a Kia in there let's
say this is targeted towards you do you
have any kind of enemies no not at all
wow really do you have maybe what do you
mean wow really I feel like everyone's
got an enemy wow someone's that well
giraffe doesn't have it editing what the
[__] you have many enemies I should have
showed up like super grungy this is like
a rarity for me you are dressed I mean
like you have enemies you do look really
nice someone who's got her car stolen I
don't I mean apparently but it doesn't
make sense for her to dress like this
because you would need to take the
Titanic if your car got stolen I love
you trying to make a report and the cops
like you don't look like your car got
stolen
you don't look stressed out you don't
look like you drive a Kia right now
that's what I was thinking in my head I
was like you know what
[__] it like like this is the situation
damn dude so did you go into the police
station looking like this yeah okay look
at this because you were already ready
to come to JK looking like this you
think she was gonna come in like should
I be wearing it like situation
[Applause]
looking like that
so there's no footage of what the dudes
actually look like or anything there's
like minimal of him getting out of the
car but like his face is is there I mean
did I zoom what was he wearing maybe
it's a quick description maybe of that
was joggers it was the same guy from the
Jessie Smollett did I zoom at 323 video
hats it looked like a jumpsuit or
something yeah I couldn't even tell what
race like it just it was shadowy in the
Josie small hair video no I'll tell you
what race goes to God
spoiler alert spoiler alert you could
tell the rice
[__] there's a little party you feel
like man like my car is pretty cool
people want to steal it that is kind of
kind of sick it's like they chose mine
Nick it's a [__] Kia what's wrong
with your well Nick drives a Hyundai
Elantra that's like a biggest piece of
[__] dude I drive a Mazda it's a Kia and
apparently a video came out about how to
do this with the USB cable which
everybody has on tick tock your car is
really nice I love that like it's an SUV
it's nice yeah well I'm pretty [__]
right now so oh man they make cool Vans
they make SUVs they make cool sedans I
love Kia yeah dude I [__] hate Kia oh
no yeah hey you know go my one bad
example spoil your experience of Kia
maybe you should switch to Toyota this
guy is the face of Toyota he is what do
you mean oh really because I'm an
ambassador they were in a Toyota Camry
where are they are you a house helping
Honda helper an accomplice
so they were in a Toyota
because the Toyota you you did the crime
in the Toyota and you escaped in the
Toyota reliable exchange Toyota how
would you turn this into a happy
holidays a happy holidays like a good
story you look like I know like a happy
holidays like your commercials oh I mean
Toyota doesn't just get you to A to B
it'll get you from A to B with something
else and get you to see it it's the
perfect assist car but that does suck
though yeah that's terrible I'm sorry
Colleen wanakia use a Toyota so then all
that can the only good thing that can
happen now is if they find it right
that's it there's no other yeah that's
that the only solution is that yeah they
find it and like Parts aren't taken out
are you pressing charges on the thieves
are you kidding I'm gonna beat their ass
myself one ringside
and then get charged with like
manslaughter because you know situations
are just that much better yeah in
Minecraft though in mine yeah you know
or I'm just gonna get a horse because at
least it can fight back
it's better than a Kia they'll bite yeah
dude forces bite I think you can hack
horses with USBS though yeah yeah but
they might be easy to steal USB ports a
good saddle yeah
maybe a carrot kind of horse do you got
don't stand behind them
sorry Colleen that sucks ass man
oh USB stands for you suck boobs you
were close
damn yeah that's that's pretty old brand
so now that your name is officially
Carlos
um what do we do in are you are you
saying that to him or me allegedly he's
not he's saying it to the room
car loss you just pronounced incorrect
role play for a second a couple of
things that Colleen could do okay number
one she says hey you know Mark she goes
and gets full coverage and then next
week she's like yeah my car got stolen
okay but here's here's the problem okay
the kicker is thanks for this this
little pre-frame Steve you're so good at
your job
um the kicker is I filed a police a
police report this morning which means
that it's time stamped so the insurance
company is gonna cross cross reference
that and know that oh well your car was
actually stolen here but that's not
Carlos that's not Carl whatever's
Lionheart Carlos Lionheart yeah that's
the new idea I thought I came here first
I'm like yeah really change your
identity we got you no we got you Carlos
Linhart yep Jiu Jitsu oh wait what about
the tracker thing okay so
um I called Kia and they searched my VIN
number and apparently the security
system that I have is like inoperable
and the low Jack doesn't work no it's
always something like that though you
think that's just a scam because they
[__] they go would you like to
upgrade a security we're like yeah
they're like okay all of our cars have
security and then when it comes time oh
it's not working yeah oh you didn't pay
the extra 8K it's because the F10 guards
did it yeah it's like a police body cam
dude what if they were employed by Ikea
to steal your car
okay that's obviously not the case but
cool we can run with it I feel like
that's not good for Kia you know what I
think I feel like that's a really bad
idea for kids I think the only thing you
can do Colleen is go on Tick Tock watch
the video of how to steal a Kia and just
steal the kids just rotate that
ownership because honestly what you're
telling me or I might as well just like
do insurance fraud at this point yeah
because it sounds like there's no way
out of this besides being sick yeah it's
a better content you got to be a little
sketchy does Colleen Lionheart get out
of insurance you're on you could start a
limited seriously you can start a
limited series on YouTube about
insurance for us
see how many episodes you can upload
about it I'd help you but we're on
camera yeah yeah
I probably know the guys
no so my building I guess two nights ago
uh we think it's the same people uh cars
are broken into guns were stolen out of
somebody's cars
um
yeah she didn't leave your guns in the
car you really shouldn't just leave it
on your body yeah yeah maybe it was a
rifle just couldn't hold it he's like
it's heavy he's got a nice shots
put the passenger seat and then they're
just like let's go back to that place we
we got a good loot last time yeah
anyways I think I want to move out of
state I'm I think I'm done with
California yeah no no where would you go
Las Vegas please I think maybe Las Vegas
why are you being serious do they steal
cars over there I think they probably do
more than California
is that we're gone in 60 seconds
happened in Vegas no that's Ocean's 11
bro wait no God says he's seconds that's
in Italy
you're stupid it was the Venetian That's
Italian Job yeah yeah Italian Job the
Mini Coopers and stuff have you guys
ever been in a
high stress situation where you start
calling people and you're trying to
problem solve and everybody in that job
position just doesn't know how to do
their [__] job yeah like at all yep
of course and I think that's most people
though like yeah it's called the bank I
think once you start it's called Society
once you need real solutions you start
to realize like nobody has a lot of
solutions when you care about something
you find out how much everyone else
doesn't give a [__] I called the first
person no the second person for Kia and
the guy just sounded sleepy and
instantly I was like you know what give
me somebody else you sound too sleepy
for this and then did he give you
somebody else yes I absolutely said that
what and when you talked to the other
guy dude he sounds sleepy too he sounded
too awake yeah yeah maybe they just
stole a car
I feel like I'm in a children's book
like it's so hot so cold it's a lot
going on here yeah I just got in office
if we end up finding the thieves would
you want them as guests on the show you
can ask them what the [__] they did that
oh you totally should have them we
should we should do that let's do that I
would love to have them on a guest
in this vicinity with me here present
well we would love the platform though
we'd love to give him a shout out dude I
can't believe that dude I mean now
they're armed if it's the same people
so I mean there's they got ghost guns on
them too well I got myself uh
I could comb my hair
bring it home to a gunfighter you know
if you have a USB you can steal Kias oh
that's right I got a USB I wonder how
easy it is to steal Ikea it's got to be
pretty easy if all these kids are doing
it man how long did it take them it was
from 2 30 to 237 and that's seven
minutes seven minutes of stealing my
Pizza Quick math we probably also have
to adjust it probably took them longer
to adjust the seat because it's tiny
yeah
not true not true Steve I I like to lean
back oh you're a leaner yeah she's all
the way in there she drives hip-hop
style yeah yeah yeah that's hip-hop
the guy's stole the car and fell all the
way back oh [__] yeah Colleen's this
[__] on the motorcycle security cam
footage monkey monkey ape hangers
all right how'd you get here how'd you
get here by the way uh my brother drops
me off oh he's cool that's good to have
up here
that's good to have a family I'm sorry
Joe it's wonderful damn dude I have
people I pay that's good enough that's
family that's cute it's better than
family when I lived in downtown
um we had like a you know like a garage
system where if you had a key fob to eat
it just the roll the bay door just rolls
up automatically it's pretty cool it
just goes real quick right and then um
the neighbor was like [__] my
motorcycle's gone and then they shared
it on the community Facebook page and
basically you see these two guys just
waiting in a truck
and then when one car comes in they
follow and then they just went up to
where everyone parked their bikes and
they just picked them up and like threw
them in the truck and then drove off and
that was it yeah so it's like even if
you have camera security it doesn't
matter there's always a way I feel like
you could steal a car now and it's like
all good kind of okay so I'm taking bets
on what do you think is gonna happen to
my car am I gonna find it is it gonna be
wrecked
um
is is are the police gonna find it and
return it will I never find it you could
scratch that last one I don't think the
police are I think I think it'll be used
in a smash and grab or something best
case scenario they use it no they use it
for a crime and they did and they just
ditch it yeah once it's ditched and
someone reports hey there's just been
this car that's been parked here for for
a month that's when they'll find or
they'll just keep on using that car to
steal a better car and and just trade
off because then the police are looking
for that license plate instead of the
one that they're actually and then the
dude's just in Ferrari by the end and
he's like man I missed that Kia
it's just a TLC
up theft up that damn so if it was
on the side of the road for a month
would it be stripped do you think like
tires seats depends on what city well
also like you're not gonna get much
money for parts for a Kia you don't say
that you don't know the keys are a fine
Automotive Nick help me help my
situation okay my feelings are hurt I
mean dude Lucky Charms right now nine
dollars for a box I think everything's
[__] expensive you know eggs are like
almost 10 bucks here some people need
Kia parts I mean you need every part
right now well that's true and also like
oh nice dude rub it in her face
do you want these two to get the death
penalty
I think say yes say yes so yeah don't
tell me hey edit yes edit yes
yes and come out of her mouth just a
different language yes yeah well
hopefully they find it man I think
they're gonna find it yeah I feel like
they'll just use it for one more illegal
thing and then just yeah I hope it's
just like left I just hope there's no
like piss in it or something gross hobo
[__] session there or something yeah
yeah yeah
I didn't say that at least a bunch of
hobos [__] in it you could still use
it to get from A to B yeah that's true
yeah and it's only the bad seat they're
not doing nothing from A to B and smell
like pee homos have respect for the
front seat yeah how would you know damn
they just don't cut the leg room in the
front wait none of you guys have ever
had a car stolen no this is my first
well one time and hopefully my last so
when I I started having trust issues
because one time my truck ran out of gas
and then I had to buy a gas can and walk
with the gas back to my truck and then
the next morning I go and look at the
back of my truck and the gas can is gone
I was like son of a gun because I left
it on the street
yeah and then somebody [__] stole my
gas can do you feel seen right now yeah
do you see the look the same same thing
same thing so I kind of know how it
feels but except they didn't even need a
USB for me it probably took much quicker
but yeah
I get it I get it is this like talking
to your parents underneath the shoe yeah
same thing yeah same same yeah same same
it's like talking to your folks right
um no I think my family is pretty
understanding pretty supportive I'm
pretty intelligent apparently are we
pretty sure
I feel like that but you probably feel a
little violated and little like oh wow
no not at all I I feel like people
should steal my car more often going
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign